now if you're a regular viewer you
probably know by now that Sky News has
been campaigning for an independent
Commission to oversee leaders debates at
general elections and we're joined now
by a Conservative MP Peter bone who
thinks that they are a good idea and
before we get to the leaders debates I
just want to ask you about a few things
that Matt Han culture said in that
interview he said that if MPs have gone
back to their constituencies and talk to
normal people then they should be ready
to back the prime ministers deal so are
you that's not quite what he said I
heard what he said he said he went back
to his constituents and he and what they
said to him was get on with it and
that's absolutely true and the only way
you're going to get on and deliver
brexit is what's called a no deal brexit
and then at the end of March next year
we'll be out of the EU we will have left
there was no question that I remember on
the referendum about a deal or not it
was leave or remain and the way you
leave is to come out on the 29th of
March so he wasn't it wasn't I'm not
accusing him not telling you the truth
but what he actually said was he went
back and people told him to get on with
him that's exactly what they tell all
MPs and that they want to come out on 20
nights of March they want to actually
leave do you think that MPs have changed
their minds over the Christmas break
because that was clearly what number
time was hoping well if there's been any
change its hardening attitude of MPs
towards what's called a no deal because
the more and more information about the
no deal is clear that it's absolutely ok
to do it we had the Secretary of State
they're just saying there's no problem
on the health front we had a senior
civil servant come out and say we're
well prepared for inaudi land of course
the government isn't saying that because
they're trying to get through their um
their so-called a bricks it deal it
wasn't quite soon there's no problem on
the health front he was saying that the
plans are in place to try and mitigate
any of the consequences no I think he
actually I was listening very carefully
he said there wasn't going to be no
problems with drugs and all the plans
were in place I I couldn't see you asked
him to give a guarantee I don't think he
could have given much more of a
guarantee than he did now you want to
call Tory's made of bricks a queen said
that she would be Carrie
shoulder-high through the streets the
echoing of cheering crowds as she
visited your constituency after brexit
do you think that's still the case
I think you left a little bit out I
think I said if she delivered the brexit
the people voted for and when I said
that it looked like we were going to do
that now cause it looks like we're gonna
do anything but that and I'm afraid the
statute I was going to build in
Wellingborough to mrs. Mayes were
probably not going to happen now what do
you think the reaction in your questions
would be so mrs. may still them well at
the moment they're very frustrated they
want to have a the brexit a vote if all
they wanted to end the free movement of
people not paid billions of billions of
pounds each and every year to to the EU
make their own our own laws in her own
country just by our own judges and
clearly mrs. Mays deal falls on all
those fronts so I don't think she would
get a particular should get a plight
reception but not a good researcher cm
Prime Minister is holding drinks parties
with their some conservative MPs at this
week have you got an invitation you they
were chasing me up yesterday wherever I
could go one unfortunately I'm speaking
and speaking in the sky and you
effectively the Sky News debate when one
of those perceptions is going on and the
other one I don't think I can make
either but they were chasing me up okay
well let's talk about the debate shall
we because tomorrow there is going to be
this debate in Parliament about the sky
news a campaign to try and get an
independent commission to look at
leaders debates in general elections
what's your view well I think first
world on Sky News and getting and what
close 150,000 people to sign the
petition is fantastic and we can have
this debate three-hour debate in the
second chamber of the House of Commons
tomorrow and that's wonderful and I have
a private member's bill which I've
introduced the second reading of that
bill is in March and it'll be the debate
will very very useful in anything that
comes up in that debate that I haven't
already thought of can go into to my
bill but the advantage of the debate and
what Sky News has done it's got the
public involved and put the pressure on
the government it would have been very
easy for the for the government just to
say about my bill well it's quite a good
idea but we're not going to do it Peter
but the pressure from the public I think
helps us achieve what we want why do you
think there seems to be this reluctance
from the government to press ahead with
it well I think all governments are the
same if they think that they can win
they're not going to have a debate that
they say they will have a debate and
they'll keep it and then of course it
never happened because that's too much
risk yes too much risk so when we if we
can have an independent commission it
will be compulsory for the leaders
debate so there will be two in my bill
there will be two leaders debates in the
regulated period between the Prime
Minister and leader of the opposition
and there'll be one debate where all the
leaders of the parties representing the
House of Commons would take part and
there'll be proper debates it wouldn't
be just like you ask question then you
ask the other person no this will be a
debate between the leaders so each of
the leaders could come back and debate
with the other what the other person has
said that's what we need to test our
future Prime Minister in that way I
think and there could be an election
sooner than we think potentially so this
is something we probably have to get on
with
yes well I'm my private member's bill is
in in March if both the government and
the opposition support it we can get it
through a non statute statutory box make
it an act of Parliament if you like
within a few months okay